let's bring in arkansas republican
senator tom cotton so i want to ask you
about the the migs because the united
states was pushing poland to send them
into ukraine poland said we're not going
to do that but we will give them to you
united states at ramstein air base for
you to do whatever you like with them
here's how jen sachi tried to explain
her way out of that not being a good
idea
i think it's pretty clear it doesn't
require a military expert to understand
why having planes
fly from a u.s air base into a contested
part of the country where there is a war
is not in our interests and not in nato
interests
so she said i don't understand how it's
in oranges or nato interest to send them
from an american air base into ukraine
but it's fine to send them from a polish
nato air base into ukraine yeah john i
literally don't understand what the
administration is saying here this is
just more dithering more hesitating half
measures you know we've seen this time
and again whether it's on central bank
sanctions or on the international
payment systems known as swift versus
stinger aircraft missiles male russian
oil imports the administration doesn't
want to do something doesn't want to do
something and ultimately it follows
congress or it follows our nato allies
the administration said just two days
ago the secretary of state said that
we'd give a green light to poland
transferring these migs when poland
turned around and said well actually
we'd like you to do it because we're
smaller than you are and we're right
next to russia in a way you're not the
administration said no we couldn't
possibly do that it would be escalatory
well how would it be escalatory for the
united states to transfer these polish
aircraft as opposed to poland a nato
ally to transfer them and it is bigger
than this as well john it's not just
this polish aircraft there are other
eastern european countries that used to
be in the warsaw pact under soviet
russia's dominion that have other kinds
of aircraft they have other kinds of
missiles they have other kind of enemy
air defenses that we would probably like
to see transferred as well so this is
going to continue to play out it's time
for the administration to stop slow
rolling things to stop asking lawyers to
take the lead it's time for leaders to
take the lead and that's what president
biden needs to do
senator we look at the situation on the
ground there and i'm sorry i'm looking
down i'm just trying to get brand new
details
on this horrific situation in mary opal
of the maternity ward there and
the warnings that there are children in
the rubble and just how horrific of an
attack
that is and you just wonder uh what the
hours and days look like ahead as
benjamin hall was just reporting to us
that you know obviously keeve in the
coming days and in fact 24 hours from
now is the assessment
could be under a much different
situation than it is right now
sandra this is why
uh we're in a matter situation where
it's not days that matter not even hours
but minutes and every minute the
administration spins with lawyers
tinkering over details about whether we
can transfer stinger missiles whether
poland can transfer these aircrafts or
we can take this that or the other step
is the risk of ukrainian lives lost they
need to start moving at the speed of
warfare not the speed of bureaucracy to
try to help the uh ukrainian army and
really all the ukrainian people defend
themselves from this brutal aggression
by vladimir putin yeah senator let me
just swing back to the migs by raising
this idea that
russia would like to make this about a
confrontation between russia and the
united states dmitry peskov the kremlin
mouthpiece said that the united states
is waging economic war
against russia do you expect that russia
will try to retaliate in some way
economically and if the united states
were to take those polish migs and
transfer them from ramstein to ukraine
could russia then say a direct
act of aggression by the united states
and spread that information across
russia to say we told you the united
states with a bad guy in this
john they might say that but how is that
any different from providing
ukraine with anti-tank missiles that are
killing russian soldiers how is that any
different from providing them
anti-stinger missiles that shoot down
russian aircraft if we sit back on our
back foot and we allow vladimir putin to
set the terms then we might as well just
see ukraine and all of europe and
ultimately all of north america as well
we cannot allow vladimir putin to set
the terms on which we are going to
support a sovereign nation ukraine to
defend itself against brutal aggression
the administration's posture reminds me
a little bit about what u.s grant said
in 1864 when he took over the entire
union army and all the generals in the
army of the potomac after three years of
fighting robert e lee were obsessing
about what lee was going to do and grant
said i'm so tired of hearing about what
you think lee is going to do you think
he's going to turn a double
somersault and land on our rear and both
of our flanks at the same time you
should go back to your commands and
decide what we're going to do to lee
that's what nato should be doing that's
what the united states should be doing
we should get on the front front foot
quit dithering quit hesitating and take
the initiative to help the people of
ukraine defend their territory
senator i'll ask you to be more specific
on that in just a moment as i quote
vladimir zielinski saying people
children are under the wreckage uh in
mariopol calling this an atrocity he
went on uh to talk about the the
blocking of humanitarian aid to these
people saying russian forces are holding
hostage more than 400 000 people
from humanitarian aid evacuation
from mariopol
what do you mean uh we should be on our
front foot be more specific how should
we be responding yes sandra take for
instance these polish migs rather than
waiting for poland to take action rather
than over lawyering the situation when
poland does we should be leaning forward
having encouraged poland to transfer
these aircraft and any other aircraft
and weapons they had days ago the same
thing with other former warsaw pac
nations like slovakia and hungary and
romania and bulgaria many of these
countries want to support ukraine
even more than they already are but when
you have the united states and perhaps
some of our other western european nato
allies being very hesitant and cautious
about it they're less likely to put
forward that support because they're at
even greater risk of
can i just follow up to that one second
because jen sachi was asked about this
just a moment ago and also jen griffin
just spoke about this at the pentagon
and the logistical hurdles that saki
said are involved in poland providing
these migs to ukraine her words she said
carting them down the street is not as
easy as you may think they have to be
taken apart and put back together you
have to have people who can do so to
that you say what
first i would say jinsaki is not exactly
a military or logistical expert and
second our department of defense has
unfortunately got a lot of lawyers in
there as well that is going to find
every reason in the world not to take
action that we should this reminds me a
little bit in 1973 when israel's back
was up against the wall in the yom
kippur war and the department of defense
and the department of state was finding
every reason not to act and richard
nixon said send every plane that flies
with everything that shoots and that
helped lead that war to a stalemate so
israel wasn't overrun that's what this
president should be doing right now with
the stubborn bureaucracy that's giving
every reason in the world not to take
more action to help the people of
ukraine i guess there are a couple of
ways that you can get those migs to
ramstein you could take them apart box
them up and ship them over land or you
could put a pilot in it and fly it there
and then fly it from ramstein into
poland but again this is all presenting
logistical problems that the united
states can't seem to get over let me ask
you about oil uh because the buy
administration has now banned the sale
of russian oil ban the import of russian
oil some private companies were doing
that already but there doesn't seem to
be any kind of a concrete plan to back
up the loss of that oil and it may not
be that significant but the wall street
journal is reporting that we have gone
or we're trying to go to saudi arabia
and the uae
to get them to pump more oil and we're
rebuffed the wall street journal writing
saudi transport crown prince mohammad
bin salman and the uh sheikh mohammed
mid zayat on the high end both declined
u.s requests to speak to mr biden in
recent weeks the official said saudi and
emirati officials have become more vocal
in recent weeks than their criticism of
american policy in the gulf the the
white house pushed back on this saying
oh no he talked to uh
he talked to the king back on february
the 9th
uh but this idea that we're trying to
get more oil from saudi arabia and from
dictators like maduro and from iran to
backstop us as opposed to going with u.s
energy does that make any sense to you
no john it makes no sense whatsoever it
was the right step to ban russian oil
imports we could start producing more
oil here in a matter of weeks if not
days if the administration would stop
its war on american oil and gas um we
probably could have gotten more
production from saudi arabia in the
united arab emirates if president biden
hadn't been shunning those two nations
and intentionally ostracizing them for
the last 14 months muhammad bin zayed in
the emirates in particular is one of
america's strongest allies and supporter
in the middle east and president biden
has given them the cold shoulder for the
last 14 months as they've been under
attack by iran's proxies and now look
where we're turning we're turning to the
ayatollahs in iran who still chant death
to america or in venezuela we're going
to a dictator nicholas maduro who our
government doesn't even recognize as the
legitimate head of state of venezuela
when all we have to do is turn to
america's oil and gas workers in places
like arkansas and louisiana and texas
and north dakota and encourage them and
their investors to get american oil
flowing again
um i mean that's that's the crux of the
issue right i mean we're all having
these conversations every single it
looks so obvious senator it looks so
obvious that we have a ton of these
resources right here to be tapped into
our neighbors canada mexico plenty of
oil
why are we why are we even talking about
turning to iran
venezuela saudi arabia i mean obviously
huge producing countries but we know
based on the last couple years how we
can be
we can be energy independent
sandra it's mystifying other than the
fact that these eco activists in the
democratic party just want to feel good
about themselves about killing american
oil and gas production i mean if they're
worried about greenhouse gas emissions
where obviously iran and venezuela is
going to create even more missions
because they don't have the same kind of
advanced technology we do there is no
reason that we should not be producing
more oil and gas in america right now
for that matter more nuclear power as
well that we can also help export to
europe to help them become more
independent of russian oil and gas
senator it's good of you to come in this
afternoon thanks so much for being with
us thank you john thank you senator hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else